ahora trabajemos con el inciso b en el
inciso b que dice encuentra la velocidad
promedio de la partícula en el período
de tiempo cero menor o igual que t menor
o igual que 6 entonces para resolver el
inciso b lo que quieras la velocidad
promedio y si recordamos un poco en las
fórmulas que tenemos de la física
clásica acerca de la velocidad yo tenía
que la distancia es lo mismo que la
velocidad en este caso promedio por el
tiempo o dicho de otra manera la
velocidad promedio es lo mismo que la
distancia total entre el tiempo total y
con esta fórmula voy a conseguir el
inciso b ahora bien el problema consiste
en que yo no sé la distancia total de
hecho ni siquiera tengo una ecuación
para la posición entonces para ello
encontrar esta distancia total me voy a
fijar en la ecuación de la velocidad
recuerden que la velocidad es la primera
derivada de la posición con respecto al
tiempo para entender mejor qué es lo que
está pasando voy a hacer una gráfica
comparando la velocidad con el tiempo el
tiempo lo tengo de 0 a 6 segundos y
supongamos que la gráfica de la
velocidad es esta me estoy tomando una
gráfica cualquiera porque graficar
vedete en el examen no creo que sea la
mejor estrategia además lo importante
saber cómo encontrar la distancia en
esta gráfica que tenemos para ello me
voy a fijar en un intervalo de tiempo
muy pequeño y con él voy a construir una
columna esta columna tiene una propiedad
muy importante si yo me fijo en el área
de esta columna es una buena
aproximación de la distancia en ese
tiempo muy pequeño porque porque si yo
tengo un pequeño tiempo y lo multiplicó
por la velocidad obtengo la distancia no
es así entonces si ya tengo yo una
aproximación para la distancia en un
tiempo pequeño yo puedo extender esta
idea a que el área bajo mi curva vedette
del tiempo cero el tiempo seis segundos
es mi distancia total es decir la
distancia es la integral de cero a seis
de la función btt dt y una vez que ya
obtuve la distancia total con esta
integral entonces la velocidad promedio
es la distancia entre el tiempo total
pero quien es el tiempo total el tiempo
total aquí es una diferencia de tiempo
aquí es una diferencia de tiempo y el
tiempo total serían 6 pues es la
diferencia entre el tiempo 6 segundos y
el tiempo 0 segundos que es la cantidad
de tiempo de mi intervalo ahora bien
darse cuenta que resolver el inciso b
radica entonces en encontrar la integral
de la velocidad de t y a esto dividirlo
entre 6 sin embargo la integral de la
velocidad no es una integral sencilla
pues la integral de dos veces el seno de
ea la t entre cuatro más uno no es una
integral que podamos hacer tan fácil a
mano por lo tanto voy a buscar en mi
calculadora la forma de resolver esta
integral definida para esto me hubiera
el catálogo después me voy a ir a apps y
ahora voy a fijarme en dónde está no
aquí está en fm int es decir la integral
definida la integral definida de quién
bueno la función va a ser dos veces seno
de y elevado a la t entre cuatro más uno
entonces voy a escribirlo dos veces le
voy a poner aquí que multiplica al seno
de paréntesis y elevado a la entre
cuatro en lugar de te lo voy a poner x
pero aquí me faltó un paréntesis porque
después le voy a tener que sumar 12
veces el seno y ahora sí de la función
exponencial la función exponencial
elevado a la equis es lo mismo que teo x
es una variable elevado a la paréntesis
x entre 4 a esto hay que dividirlo entre
4 vamos bien con los paréntesis si a
tengo que cerrar mis paréntesis ahora si
cierro 1 tengo que cerrar otro también y
creo que a otro también ya esto lo tengo
que sumar 1 coma
coma y ahora tengo que poner con
respecto a quién voy a integrar mi
integral en este caso es con respecto a
la variable x lo hice con respecto a la
variable x para no venderme en el
problema de ponerte en la calculadora y
de dónde a dónde a pues de 0 a 6 y ya
está ahora si tengo por fin esta forma
de resolver esta integral que es la
calculadora está buscando el valor
numérico y ya está el valor es 11 puntos
69-62 entonces esto es igual a
11.69 6 ya redondeado no me voy a meter
en problemas de 62 etcétera etcétera y
ya esto hay que dividirlo entre 6
entonces si este número yo lo divido
entre 6 ya he terminado el inciso b
entonces vamos a dividir esto entre 6 la
respuesta entre 6 es igual a
1.94 93 por lo tanto la velocidad
promedio va a ser ni más ni menos que 1
punto 94 9 que ha redondeado y como no
nos importan las unidades ya tenemos
respuesta del inciso b así que vamos con
el inciso c que dice encuentra la
distancia total recorrida por la
partícula del tiempo t igual a 0 al
tiempo t igual a 6 y tenemos mucha
suerte porque la respuesta del inciso c
ya la habíamos obtenido en el inciso b
la respuesta de la distancia total es
11.69 6 así que vámonos al inciso de que
dice lo siguiente para ser un menor o
igual que el tiempo menor o igual que el
6 la partícula cambia de dirección
exactamente una vez
exactamente una vez encuentra la
posición la posición de la partícula en
ese tiempo en ese instante vamos a ver
qué podemos hacer lo primero que sería
muy bueno analizar es entender a qué se
refiere el problema cuando dice que la
partícula cambia de dirección
exactamente una vez y es que como la
partícula se mueve solamente en un eje
cuando cambias de dirección pasa lo
siguiente la velocidad cambia de signo
puede ser positiva y cambiar a negativa
o en su dado caso ser negativa y cambiar
a positiva más intentar verlo con una
gráfica estoy comparando otra vez la
velocidad con el tiempo y supongamos que
pasa lo siguiente la velocidad es
positiva y después se vuelve negativa
cuando cambias de dirección es justo el
punto en donde pasa a ser de positiva a
negativa es decir cuando en esta gráfica
la velocidad se hace cero por ejemplo en
el otro caso donde la velocidad cambia
de ser negativa a positiva es justo
también este sitio donde la velocidad se
hace cero o dicho en otras palabras
donde la curva de la velocidad cruza al
eje del tiempo pero eso sí es muy
importante que la velocidad cambie de
signo por ejemplo en este caso la
velocidad es positiva va decreciendo
toca el eje del tiempo y después vuelve
a crecer otra vez es decir cambia de ser
positiva a cero y otra vez a ser
positiva y en ese caso no hay un cambio
de dirección por lo tanto para que mi
partículas cambios de dirección
necesitamos que mi curva de la velocidad
cruce al eje del tiempo y además cambió
de dirección exactamente una vez es
decir solamente va a cruzar una vez al
eje del tiempo por consecuente lo que
buscamos es encontrar donde la curva
pendiente se hace igual a cero
ahora bien dicho de otra manera lo que
queremos es que esta esta ecuación
vedette sea igual a cero entonces vamos
a escribirlo dos veces el seno del
elevado late entre cuatro más uno esto
es la función vedete y yo lo que quiero
es que sea igual a cero y resolver esta
ecuación es encontrar mi respuesta del
inciso de por lo tanto yo lo que quiero
es un tiempo entre 0 y 6 que resuelva
esta ecuación entonces vamos a restar
uno de los dos lados y me queda que dos
veces el seno del elevado a la 34 es
igual a menos uno o dicho de otra manera
el seno de entre cuatro es igual a menos
uno entre dos bases dividiendo el dos y
bueno esto lo podríamos buscar en la
calculadora pero como hay varios ángulos
que cumplen la propiedad que le aplicar
la función sea no nos dan menos un medio
voy a buscar los mejores en el círculo
unitario pero bueno lo que me gustaría
entender bien es esta expresión yo tengo
que el seno del elevado a la t entre 4
es igual a menos un medio es decir
elevado a la t entre 4 debe de ser un
ángulo y yo busco es un tiempo que esté
entre 0 y 6 que cumpla que el seno de eb
elevado a la 34 es decir el seno de ese
ángulo sea igual a menos un medio voy a
dibujar el círculo unitario y vamos a
darnos cuenta de quiénes son aquellos
ángulos cuyo seno es igual a menos un
medio bueno haciendo un poco de memoria
y recordando los principales ángulos que
conforman el círculo unitario nos vamos
a dar cuenta que el ángulo menos pi
sextos es el primero que cumple esta
propiedad o si lo quisiéramos ver como
un ángulo positivo tendremos que hacer
dos menos pi sextos y bueno el otro
ángulo que cumple esta propiedad que el
seno de ese ángulo es igual a menos un
medio es este de aquí es decir este
ángulo lo encontramos teniendo aquí acá
eyed peas y sumándole pi sextos y bueno
vamos a encontrar los más peak sextos
cuánto es vamos a ponerlo aquí pin más y
sextos esto es igual a 6 pi más pin todo
esto entre 6 es decir esto es lo mismo
que 7 y entre 6 y de hecho el otro
ángulo que tenemos aquí está negativo es
11 pi sobre 6 pues le restamos a 2 pi un
sexto de pinos quedarán 11 pieces sextos
y con esto ya tenemos dos soluciones
aunque también es importante recordar
que cualquier múltiplo de dos y suma dos
a estos dos ángulos sería también
solución pero para no complicarnos de
vida con una infinidad de soluciones voy
a tomar y a suponer que 7 piso de 6 es
mi solución vamos a ver si se cumple que
existe un tiempo tal que he elevado a la
t entre 4 es igual a 7 y sextos así que
vamos a intentar que se cumpla esta
igualdad yo quiero que el seno de un
ángulo es igual a menos un medio si ese
ángulo es decir el elevado a la 34 es
igual a 7 pi sextos que es lo que
habíamos encontrado y bueno resolviendo
aquí lo primero que hay que hacer es
sacar el logaritmo natural de ambos
lados es decir de entre 4 hay que
ponerlo aquí te dividido entre 4 es
igual al logaritmo natural de 7 pin
entre 6 pase del otro lado de la función
exponencial y si ahora paso el 4
multiplicando voy a obtener que t es
igual a 4 es el logaritmo natural de 7
sobre 6 así que vamos a intentar ver si
este es nuestro resultado factible en la
calculadora queremos un tiempo recuerden
entre 0 y 6 entonces cuatro veces el
logaritmo natural de abro un paréntesis
7 y donde está pin aquí sobre 6 esto es
igual a 5 puntos 1955 perfecto tuvimos
bastante suerte porque es un número que
está entre 0 y 6 es decir es nuestro
resultado esto es igual a 5 puntos 19 6
ya redondeado pero hay que tener cuidado
porque todavía no hemos encontrado la
respuesta de este inciso porque nos
piden encuentra la posición de la
partícula en ese tiempo y recuerden que
no tenemos una función explícita para la
posición la posición está dada por equis
dt pero lo que sí sabemos es que esta
posición la podemos encontrar con una
integral x 7 es igual a la integral de
cero ate de quien pues de la velocidad
recuerden que la velocidad es la
derivada del posición es decir la
integral de 0 a t de la velocidad que
depende del tiempo diferencial de más
una constante ahora nosotros tenemos
unas condiciones esenciales que no hemos
usado aquí arriba nos decían que x de 0
es igual a 2 y nunca ha mostrado eso
entonces si nosotros usamos que x de 0
es igual a 2 en esta definición de x dt
voy a obtener que x de 0 es igual a la
integral de 0 a 0
dvd t diferencial de más una constante
pero esto tiene que ser igual a 2 por el
valor que nos dan ahora esta integral
pues vale 0 y con esto obtenemos el
valor de la constante la constante vale
2 y si sustituimos este valor de la
constante yo voy a obtener que x 7 está
dado por la integral de 0 a t de mi
función velocidad diferencial de t más 2
y bueno ya con esto podemos encontrar la
posición tras la que andamos si
sustituimos al tiempo x 5.196 vamos a
hacerlo la posición en el tiempo
5.196 va a ser igual a la integral de 0
a
5.196 dvd t
dt + 2 entonces vamos a usar otra vez la
calculadora y de manera análoga a como
lo hicimos en el inciso b voy a sacar el
catálogo después voy a buscar la
integral
definida que era la función que teníamos
aquí
está aquí efe int entonces la integral
definida de primero voy a poner la
función que era vez de kirchner a veces
se acuerdan de dvd dvd
de hecho la tenemos aquí la calculadora
estas vez dt entonces vamos a escribirla
teníamos la integral definida de
paréntesis paréntesis dos veces el seno
de la función exponencial elevado a la x
entre 4 recuerden que estoy tomando a la
variable x como variable de integración
todo esto cierro paréntesis
cierro tres paréntesis otra vez
paréntesis y esto lo tengo que sumar 1
de la variable de integración que es
equis y de dónde a dónde pues en esta
ocasión va a ser de 0 y no vamos a parar
en 6 tenemos que parar en el valor que
teníamos queda 5.196 o mejor lo voy a
poner como la respuesta anterior
entonces de la respuesta anterior cierro
paréntesis y todo esto a todo esto de
aquí le tengo que sumar 2 pues ya use el
valor inicial que me daban entonces a
todo esto le sumamos 2 y dejamos que la
calculadora piense un poquito y voy a
obtener ya la respuesta correcta que es
14.13 47 y ya está nuestra posición
final es igual a 14 puntos
134 un poquito más redondeado